[Music]
on this monday night a diplomatic
standoff between the u.s and china why
the u.s has decided on a diplomatic
boycott of the beijing olympics it
cannot be business as usual what it
means for american athletes will canada
follow suit and how the chinese
government could retaliate ottawa's new
promise and timeline to release
thousands of residential school records
it is information that we shouldn't be
sitting on oil starts moving again
through the trans mountain pipeline why
the shutdown pushed down gas prices and
from floods to freezing weather there's
mud at the bottom of the stairs and i
couldn't even shovel out new
complications add to the mess and the
misery in merit bc
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada is considering whether to join
the us in a diplomatic boycott of the
2022 olympics in beijing china u.s
athletes will still compete but a white
house spokesperson says the united
states will not contribute to the
fanfare of the games by sending
political leaders and diplomats the u.s
cites what it calls egregious human
rights abuses by the chinese government
canada and the u.s are among a number of
countries that have declared china's
treatment of its uyghur minority
population a genocide and there's still
uncertainty about the freedom and safety
of chinese tennis pro pung shui who had
disappeared from public view after
accusing a senior communist official of
sexual assault
with the beijing olympics set to begin
in just 60 days the pressure on china is
ramping up mike armstrong has our top
story tonight
after weeks of will they or won't they
the announcement was almost businesslike
the diplomatic boycott of the beijing
games by the u.s confirmed without
fanfare or politicians posturing simply
a short statement the biden
administration will not send any
diplomatic or official representation to
the beijing 2022 winter olympics and
paralympic games
many western governments have been under
pressure to have some sort of a boycott
some way of sending a message to china
over among other issues threats to
taiwan the crackdown in hong kong and
human rights abuses in tibet and against
muslim uighurs
the official chinese stance appears to
have two somewhat different angles on
the boycott on the one hand a foreign
ministry spokesman said monday it was
little more than politicians
grandstanding
he says no one cares whether they come
or not but on the other hand that same
spokesman warned that in the event of a
boycott it would affect relations and
china would take what he called quote
now the international olympic committee
has been trying to avoid athletes
getting caught in the middle the limited
us boycott means the athletes will
compete canadian ioc member dick pound
says it was expected and is appropriate
a diplomatic boycott
is a way of sending
a message from one government to another
and that's that's what should be
happening here what pound does question
is how effective a boycott will be if
it's only the u.s canada's minister of
sports says a decision hasn't been made
we are of course very preoccupied with
the violations of human rights in china
it's not a decision that we're going to
take lightly
now how likely is it canada follow suit
well perhaps not as likely as it would
have been just a few years ago
ottawa has just come out of a bitter
protracted dispute with china over mong
won joe and the two michaels countries
have seen what challenging china can
mean i'm not certain that this is the
type of thing that canada australia and
new zealand
want to race into
when they have enough economic problems
of their own without adding to it
pulling diplomats out of the games is
basically just symbolic that said the
repercussions for canada could be very
real
mike armstrong global news montreal
canada will soon have a new person
handling the diplomatic relationship
with china dominic barton a former
executive in a consulting firm is
stepping down as ambassador at the end
of the month prime minister justin
trudeau appointed him in 2019 and tasked
him with freeing canadians michael
coverig and michael spavor from chinese
detention that job is done but there are
plenty of other challenges with china
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is with me david
well donna it's not just a potential
boycott of the beijing olympics the
trudeau government also has to make a
decision about huawei's presence on
canadian telecommunications networks
about ongoing trade irritants and what
to do about the hundred or so canadian
citizens still in chinese jails i don't
think there's any canadian who doesn't
feel
that canadian relations with china are a
mess
the government's political opponents say
dominic barton's departure should spark
a reset of its china policy i think that
the government has been has been weak on
developing a plan for china and i'd
certainly like to see a stronger
plan going forward but there could be no
new plans for china so long as the two
michaels were being held hostage now
that they are free china experts believe
there will indeed be a new approach
towards beijing i think we're going to
be going down a new path on china
in the coming months in fact almost
every western democracy is struggling to
chart a new path with china we've seen a
much more aggressive china over the last
three years than we ever saw before and
that's
affecting
the policies of not just canada but the
us uk eu
many many other countries those in the
west are in general agreement that the
response to a newly belligerent china
must be a coordinated one you know
canada is a middle power we clearly need
to work with our allies we clearly need
to work with others in um in europe with
our with our friends in the united
states the trudeau government is in fact
within weeks of announcing what it calls
an indo-pacific policy one that will
stress multilateralism and
diversification of trade away from china
dominic barton's successor the next
ambassador to china will play a key role
in executing on that strategy donna okay
david aiken in ottawa thanks the federal
government says it will finally turn
over thousands of documents on canada's
government-funded and church-run
residential schools to the national
center for truth and reconciliation it's
long been criticized for withholding the
records now canada's crown indigenous
relations minister says it's the
government's moral duty abigail beeman
explains what's at stake
we thought we were less than
and i grew up thinking like that
that i was less than
and that i was not to ever challenge
mary corchain spent 10 long years in
residential school she used to call them
canada's dirty little secret now she's
glad people are listening to stories
like hers it's important to you know if
we think about our generations our
future generations
and
that they know
that they know what we went through
she's also pleased with the government's
commitment to turn over 12 000 documents
relating to the residential school
system records it previously argued it
couldn't release due to third party
obligations to various catholic church
orders it is information that shouldn't
we shouldn't be sitting on simply
because we have third party disclosure
obligations to uh
to religious orders that were part and
parcel of
of all the damage that's been caused the
minister of crown indigenous relations
says it will take between 30 and 45 days
to hand over the documents to the
national center for truth and
reconciliation the nctr would not do an
interview but welcomes the announcement
saying in a statement this release is a
significant moment for survivors and for
canada and a major step towards
accountability and a stronger
understanding of the legacy of
residential schools all the documents
that are within the hands of the justice
department need to be turned over the
police evidence the court evidence the
records that they have of the known
predators this material needs to be
transparent it needs to be searchable it
needs to be accessible
and we need a full some document
turnover terpelafon is calling for an
external review of how canada handled
catholic entities the government
abandoned its appeal of a 2015 court
ruling that let the church off the hook
from financial obligations to
residential school survivors and all
this comes as a contingent of indigenous
leaders from canada heads to the vatican
later this month to meet the pope
they're calling for an apology
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the pharmaceutical company merck has
announced a deal to manufacture its new
covid19 antiviral pill in canada the
company says it is partnering with
thermo fisher scientific to produce mole
nu piravir at a facility in whitby
ontario it will be one of three
manufacturing sites worldwide the
antiviral pill is still under review by
health canada merck says if approved
pills made in ontario would be
distributed across canada and around the
world the merck pill is one of two oral
antiviral medications awaiting approval
in canada jamie morocco reports on
merck's new manufacturing deal and the
role antivirals could play in the fight
against covid19
it's the sweet sound of science soon to
be heard right here at home inside this
whitby ontario plant merck's covet
antiviral pill malnupiravir will be made
and shipped across the country to the uk
and around the world this is another way
to combat this pandemic
help save lives accelerate patient
recovery and avoid hospitalizations
reducing that risk by 30 percent
according to the drug maker's data a dip
from its original 50 percent projection
but an option experts say is better than
what covid patients have now when
patients are hospitalized with covet 19
it is often too late to treat them with
antivirals and you can only treat the
damage that the viruses caused
with a pill it's not only easier to take
than other treatments you can also take
it earlier at least once it's approved
it's meant to be used in a clinical
setting for people who are
for sure have been exposed and are about
to develop symptoms in the uk
molnupiravir is already being used with
some success it was recommended by the
u.s fda last week canada has already
secured half a million courses of
merck's drug with an option to buy more
it also has its eye on pfizer's
antiviral covid pill paxlavid said to
reduce severe outcomes by almost 90
percent both pills are still being
reviewed by health canada we are
choosing as canadian to be ready for
whatever may come next
a promise to improve our pandemic
response with a boost to our
biomanufacturing sector it's going to be
a combination of the two vaccines and
potentially these antivirals that will
be helpful to get us out of this welcome
news as a new variant reminds us the
pandemic is far from over jamie morocco
global news toronto
for a long time cruise ships were docked
now some are back in action and one is
reporting an outbreak of kovig 19
including a suspected case of the
omicron variant officials say the case
was detected in a crew member on the
norwegian cruise line ship breakaway 17
people on board have now tested positive
for the virus the ship returned to new
orleans on sunday after a week-long
cruise more than 3 200 people were on
board the cruise line says all guests
and crew were required to be vaccinated
the people who tested positive were
reportedly asymptomatic they've been
told to self-isolate and every passenger
had to be tested before leaving the ship
an american religious group says three
more hostages have been released in
haiti after they were kidnapped seven
weeks ago five of the 17 missionaries
who were kidnapped in october have now
been freed a canadian from ontario was
one of the people taken it's not clear
if they are among those released the
group was kidnapped by a notorious
haitian street gang after visiting an
orphanage christian aid ministry says
the people freed last night are now safe
and in good spirits global affairs
canada says it's aware of reports more
people were released but says it can't
comment further for privacy reasons
the ousted civilian leader of myanmar
aung tsuchi has been convicted in what
has been widely denounced as a sham
trial
supporters of the deposed leader took to
the streets after the verdict sushi has
been found guilty of inciting dissent
and breaking covet rules a military
court initially sentenced her to four
years then reduced it to two years the
76 year old is facing multiple other
charges since the military coup last
february some of them include violating
the state secrets act and the illegal
possession of walkie-talkies if found
guilty on all the charges she could
spend the rest of her life in prison
more than ten thousand people have been
arrested more than thirteen hundred
others have been killed since the
military coup in myanmar tsuchi's trial
was closed to the public her lawyers
barred from speaking about the case to
the media
when the oil stopped moving in bc gas
prices actually went down we'll tell you
why coming up plus forget fun in the sun
the tropical destination now under a
blizzard warning and finders keepers the
big windfall for a mountain climber
[Music]
the trans mountain pipeline has been
switched on again and will begin moving
crude oil and gas from alberta to the
west coast it was shut down three weeks
ago as a precaution when severe weather
caused catastrophic flooding and
landslides that triggered gas rationing
on the south coast of bc and as robin
gill reports it's going to stay in place
for a while yet
the trans mountain pipeline is a
critical piece of infrastructure in
western canada the restart button has
been cautiously pushed to get the oil
flowing this will not be an immediate
fix and it will take some time to resume
normal operations the pipeline normally
ships 300 000 barrels of oil per day
from alberta to british columbia for use
here and in washington state and to
export overseas but the floods three
weeks ago forced tmx to shut it down to
check for any leaks or breaks
that had a domino effect on the
refineries with no oil coming in no gas
went out i would be surprised if they
hadn't drawn down their reserves to too
close to nothing especially as they had
to shut down the refinery
that has trickled down to drivers the
province limited each fill up to 30
liters at first it sparked panic at the
pumps then something interesting
happened at gas stations when the
rationing first started the average
price of regular fuel was a dollar
sixty-two per liter but it started
dropping and at one point in december it
was a dollar fifty-three
gas price watchers attributed to british
columbians quickly appreciating the
reality of the crisis there was no
gouging
there was no profiteering there was
instead a concerted effort to
everyone looking after everyone's
interests the situation may serve as a
lesson for the province to start storing
greater reserves in case of future
emergencies like earthquakes it's
significant because when we are looking
at the supplies we only have that much
product stored and eventually will run
out of it and
luckily we have avoided disaster the
pipeline will take at least a week
before it's back operating at a hundred
percent then it'll take more time for
the refinery to ramp back up so that
still leaves limits on how much gas
drivers can get at least until december
14th robin gill global news vancouver
ahead indonesians search for the dead
after a devastating volcanic eruption
severe weather is walloping the hawaiian
islands forecasters say the storm system
could drop over 60 centimeters of rain
in some areas there are flash flood
warnings in effect for several islands
including oahu maui and the big island
and there is a blizzard warning for
hawaii's highest summits the storm is
expected to last until tomorrow the u.s
national weather service warns the storm
could produce catastrophic flooding and
strong winds
in indonesia the death toll is rising
after a devastating volcanic eruption on
java island at least 22 people are
confirmed to have died dozens of others
are still missing the volcano erupted
saturday burying towns and villages
crews have been digging through the mud
searching for victims people in the area
have been told to stay away and the
situation remains highly volatile
because the volcano is still erupting
a mountain climber has been given the
jewels he found on a french glacier more
than 50 years after they were lost in a
plane crash the treasure trove of
emeralds rubies and sapphires was buried
for decades near mont blanc in france
they're believed to have belonged to a
passenger killed in one of two air india
flights that crashed in 1950 and 1966
a mountaineer stumbled across the gems
in 2013 he turned them in authorities
say efforts to track down the owner's
family failed the precious stones worth
nearly half a million dollars will now
be shared between the climber and local
authorities
returning to merit bc next the
frustrations after a flooding
catastrophe
in the coming weeks many of us will be
home for the holidays in parts of
british columbia that's going to be
difficult if not impossible after being
forced out by flooding and weeks of
extreme weather people in merit are
returning to a community in need of a
multitude of repairs mike drale reports
they may have hoped for the best when
they were forced to leave everything
behind three weeks ago but the residents
of merit bc knew deep down they'd be
returning to a changed city and when
they entered their homes they barely
recognized them for what they were i
just got back this last this weekend and
everything was frozen there's mud at the
bottom of the stairs and i couldn't even
shovel out the damage to this south
central city was extensive roads and
bridges were wiped out the water and
sewage stopped working and the hospital
was shut down
the city as officials so bluntly put it
wasn't safe
yet residents were eager to return
because water damage compounds over time
you want to be in here right away just
to get all the water and moisture out so
you don't get molds in behind the walls
it's fair to say residents from the
fraser valley up into the interior could
use a breaker too but winter isn't
really helping the snow may look nice
but it's a superficial mass to problems
that won't go away the one intractable
fact is the scope of the disaster
there's only so many electricians or
plumbers or construction workers
especially for more remote communities
and there's certainly not enough to help
everyone in a hurry had no information i
don't even know if my water's on or off
i don't know how to get a hold of
anybody to get the water off if it is on
you know i mean if if the pipes burst
and then it thaws again
then i'll have more water in my basement
and how can they not be frustrated the
city has deemed
366 homes unlivable a number that is
almost certain to rise
the flood of 2021 may be seeing its
waters drain out of merit but the good
people who live there still feel like
they're underwater mike dralet global
news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is park and tilford gardens in
north vancouver bc we'd love to see your
canada especially festive and joyful
ones this time of year please email your
photo to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you